Aquiles retó a la tortuga
a una carrera de 10 km.
Sintiéndose bastante confiado en su rapidez,
Aquiles dio a la tortuga 2 horas de ventaja
para después correr lo más rápido que pudo
a una velocidad constante.
¿Cuál de las siguientes gráficas
describe la relación entre la posible velocidad
a la cual Aquiles corrió, en kilómetros por hora,
y la duración de su carrera
a esa velocidad en horas
incluyendo las 2 horas de ventaja?
Para empezar
te invito a que le des pausa al vídeo
y trates de determinar
¿cuál de estas gráficas describe la relación
entre la posible velocidad
a la cual Aquiles corrió
en kilómetros por hora?
es este eje que tenemos aquí.
¿Y la duración de la carrera
cuánto tiempo le tomó
incluyendo las 2 horas de ventaja?
Para poder analizar estas gráficas,
empecemos recordando,
que distancia es igual a velocidad
por tiempo
o podemos decir que es igual a
tasa de cambio
por duración.
En todas las gráficas tenemos duración
como la variable dependiente
y la velocidad, la tasa de cambio,
como la variable independiente
y sabemos que es una carrera de 10 km.
Así es que podemos escribir esto como
tiempo es igual a distancia sobre velocidad
lo que equivale a que tiempo es igual a
distancia que son 10 kilómetros
sobre
la velocidad...
sobre la velocidad.
Ahora podemos hacer una pequeña tabla
en la cual le demos
distintos valores a la velocidad
para ver cuáles serían
los valores correspondientes al tiempo.
Muy bien, veamos eso.
Aquí voy a tener
la columna con la velocidad
aunque no hay mucho espacio aquí,
si me da para poner 2, 3 valores...
y acá voy a poner la columna con el tiempo,
con la duración de la carrera
elegimos entonces un valor para la velocidad,
vemos que la velocidad va,
de 2 hasta 18,
empecemos con una velocidad de 2 km/h.
Vamos a calcular a 2 km/h
cuál sería la duración
de la carrera de Aquiles
entonces, el tiempo es...
la distancia que son 10 kilómetros
dividido entre la velocidad
que son 2 km/h
muy bien, ahora,
recordemos que
las unidades las podemos tratar como números
no son exactamente números
pero eso es lo maravilloso
del análisis dimensional.
Entonces para hacer este cálculo
voy a multiplicar 10 kilómetros
por el recíproco de 2 km/h,
entonces tenemos,
10 kilómetros
o el recíproco de 2 que es 1/2
por el recíproco de kilómetros por hora
que es hora por kilómetros
y esto hace sentido,
porque si tenemos
kilómetros sobre
kilómetros por hora...
bueno no me voy a meter en eso,
lo interesante aquí es que estos kilómetros
se cancelan con estos kilómetros
y tenemos hora que son las unidades
en las cuales esperamos
obtener el tiempo.
Y aquí tenemos entonces que el tiempo va a ser
10 por 1/2 son 5 horas.
Vamos a borrar esto al fin ya hicimos el cálculo,
y no queremos amontonarnos aquí,
así es que borró esto
y escribimos el resultado de que
la duración de la carrera de Aquiles,
cuando su velocidad es 2 km/h
es de 5 horas.
Veamos ahora cuál de estas gráficas es consistente
con este punto que acabamos de obtener
pero espera,
aquí no hemos incluido las 2 horas
que le da Aquiles de ventaja a la tortuga,
así es que esta duración tendría que ser
5 más 2, más 2 horas
tenemos que incluir estas 2 horas
que le da de ventaja Aquiles,
más 2 horas es igual a 7 horas
para que quede claro lo que acabo de hacer
dividí 10 entre  2 para obtener que la duración
de la carrera de Aquiles era 5 horas
pero a eso tenemos que sumarle las 2 horas de ventaja que le dio a la tortuga
así es que tenemos 7 horas.
Veamos cuál de estas gráficas
es consistente con eso
2 kilómetros por hora
7 horas
aquí estaría,
pero vemos que ese punto no está incluido en la gráfica
así es que esta gráfica
no corresponde
2 kilómetros por hora,
7 horas
este punto si se encuentra sobre la gráfica,
2 kilómetros por hora 7 horas,
aquí no está sobre la gráfica,
2 kilómetros por hora y 7 horas,
tampoco está sobre esta gráfica
así es que prácticamente,
con un único punto
hemos determinado que la gráfica 2,
es la que corresponde.
Ahora,
otra manera resolver esto,
sin necesidad de encontrar el valor de un punto
es considerar
que si yo voy rápido,
si yo corro rápido,
hago menos tiempo
mientras que si voy lento...
si voy lento hago más tiempo,
eso es mínimo sentido común
y así en esta gráfica
cuando voy lento
hago más tiempo
y cuando voy rápido hago menos tiempo,
ésta hace sentido
en esta de aquí cuando voy lento,
hago más tiempo
y cuando voy rápido,
hago menos tiempo
inclusive hay un tiempo límite que son dos horas,
las dos horas que le dan aquí les de ventaja la tortuga
así es que está
hace sentido también,
en la siguiente gráfica,
tenemos que si voy lento hago menos tiempo,
pero si voy rápido, también hago más tiempo,
así es que esta gráfica
no hace ningún sentido
y en la gráfica 4,
si voy lento hago menos tiempo,
mientras que si voy rápido hago más tiempo,
ésta tampoco hace sentido
así es que con esta lógica,
eliminaría estas dos gráficas
así es que ahora haciendo la comparación,
de estas dos gráficas,
esta primera gráfica es claramente
una función lineal con pendiente negativa
mientras que la gráfica 2
definitivamente no es una función lineal
esto se ve claramente aquí,
en la fórmula de la función,
donde "r" es la variable independiente
vemos que claramente
esto no es una función lineal,
aquí no es 10 kilómetros por "r",
es 10 kilómetros dividido entre "r"
para que fuera una función lineal
como esta que tenemos aquí
tendría que ser de la forma
"t" igual a un número "n"
que multiplica la velocidad,
más otro número "b"
donde está "m" que es la pendiente,
es un número negativo
no hay manera que puede escribir esto
de la forma que tenemos aquí,
de la forma
"t" igual a un número multiplicado...
no, número dividido entre "b"
así es que de esa manera,
podemos descartar la gráfica 1
claramente esto no es lineal,
no se puede escribir de esta forma,
así es que hemos eliminado la gráfica 1
y si graficamos esta función,
vamos a obtener
esta forma que no es lineal
te sugiero que grafiques esta función
tomando varios puntos,
para que te convenzas
como puedes ver,
hay muchas maneras de hacer esto
y te invito a que busques por tu cuenta
otras maneras,
pero definitivamente ésta que tenemos aquí,
la gráfica 2
es la que describe la relación
entre la posible velocidad la cual Aquiles corrió
y la duración de su carrera,
incluyendo las 2 horas de ventaja
si no incluyéramos
esas 2 horas de ventaja
esta gráfica la tendríamos que mover
hacia abajo en 2 unidades,
al moverla hacia abajo en 2 unidades
la gráfica se vería más o menos así...
más o menos así,
estoy moviendo todo hacia abajo
2 unidades...
pero esta incluye las 2 horas de ventaja,
es por eso que esta gráfica nunca,
nunca va a ir abajo de 2 horas,
aunque aquí les alcance
la velocidad de la luz.